you still live in Colombia you don't
live in the United States no so I grew
up in Spain yes then I moved to the UK
when my dad died when I was 18 and I
moved last year to Colombia after 25
years so do you do you get back to Spain
or to the UK or obviously you're
traveling here but probably just to do
this interview and a few other
professional
things do do you do you ever go back
knowing that there so much baggage with
your old life there or do you say no
I've got a new life I'm sticking around
Colombia I I went to Colombia with a
mission I went there not because I
wanted to move it was never in my heart
coming back again to my roads coming
back again to my family or to that place
because I always thought if the Lord
took me out of this place is because he
wanted something better but the Lord I'm
sorry you you grew up in Spain or you
grew up in Colombia Spain you grew up in
Spain I was born in Colombia but you
were born in Colombia okay got it I was
born there moved to Spain when I was
five yeah and then after my dad died
when I was 18 I moved to the UK I met my
husband there got marry have kids and
then mov back to Colombia God sent me
back there to to um establish a new
ministry and the word that the lord gave
me was I'm sending you back as I sent
Moses to his people so I believe that
also because of the experience that I
went through the occultist there so much
witchcraft in Latin America is there is
is normal it's the Daily Bread you're
walking on the street and you see people
doing witchcraft in the shops and I'm
like that for me that for me is is not
normal right seeing in the street and in
the shops like the the culture for me
was quite like shocking and uh so this
one year this year that I have been
there I have to you know again connect
to the culture to the people what what
is moving around but I believe the Lord
sent me back is because I had an
understanding of how things work on the
spiritual realm now I have been set free
and now he's taking me back to help my
people too is the Witchcraft in Latin
America is that what santoria is because
I've heard of santoria and I was
interested in it because it's got it
looks kind of Christian specifically
it's got It's got almost the aesthetic
of
Catholicism but it's totally perverted
it's to it's like an in inversion of the
religion where like there's this they
worship the uh St death
Sant so what is it though it's like a
it's just like a pagan syncretism with
Catholicism so Sania right the Sania it
has a seven orishas okay deaun Chango so
all of these godes that went the Afric
that they come from Nigeria in Nigeria
you have the seven the same one
so when the Africans you know they got
slave and they move to Cuba they move to
it this is where it's predominant the
Sania Puerto Rico Dominican Republic
these places the culture mixed with the
culture of the slaves so and this is why
you know the principality that I was
consecrated to is called the Indian waio
he's part of the three Venezuelan Powers
so there are different courts you have
the for um what's the name you have the
cor the the Indian core which is these
three Maria Leona negro Felipe Indian
Wai put that these are the the three
principalities of Venezuela but then you
have the Sania right and this is where
all of these other so all of these come
from the root of Africa these these
goddess these Demons of high rank and at
the time of doing the Sania and the
Witchcraft right what happens is that
now it has mix with Cath cism even my
great grandmother for healing she used
to use S Gregorio s Gregory for healing
and and and other saints that she that
she used to use mixing them up with this
demon stuff from Africa so exactly so
it's quite common there that you will
see Catholics so involved in Witchcraft
and they say I'm Catholic I'm going to
church and practicing and doing all but
at the same time they're doing
witchcraft someone asked me about this
this Sant Muerte and I said you know
listen I wasn't totally perfectly
catechized but I never heard of this
Santa Muerte anywhere in my catechism or
any I never read this in the Bible or in
any of my Catholic teaching and I then I
stumbled on this santoria thing that
must that must be very scandalous too
because if these people just in good
faith grow up and they think that
Catholicism is when you invoke like
demons to practice witchcraft then they
they might be doing these bad things
without even really knowing it yeah and
that was like part of my family too my
great-grandmother she used to go to
church but then she used to just go home
and be a medion so it's part especially
of the Latin culture is so strong to see
Catholics actually involved in
Witchcraft and with the Saints and all
and all of that that's why but are they
are they aware of it I just assumed that
they're not aware of it but are are
aware of the contradiction there no no
no my great grandmother s used to use
the Bible too she used to have the Bible
open in Psalms 23 Psalms 91 and even
like when my dad died you know this
white witch um she told my mom do this
prayer every night even though she was a
witch she told my mom do this prayer
Psalm 91 Psalm 23 every night and we did
that for one month every single night so
the they understand that you know
there's something in the Bible I go to
church you know but at the same time I'm
using the Saints and I'm using even like
some rituals that they do they actually
ask God to to bless and to guide and and
the Saints to to to do it intercede so
wow now what about I guess the only
other occult thing I've heard that in
invokes some Catholic practices but
flips them would be outright Satanism
where they do the Black Mass which is a
parody of the of the traditional Holy
Mass but you never got involved in
outright Satanism thank
God I didn't but I but I have an
understanding know how things in Satan
isn't work and the same thing they blow
the rituals because we were doing blow
rituals too and animal and things like
that for you were sacrificing animals
for certain rituals you know in Sania is
super common in is super common to kill
maybe a chicken or a um cows goats sorry
cows no goats things like that is is
normally part of the ritual because you
need blood one time I was walking along
Santa Monica Beach in California and
underneath Santa Monica piure my buddy
and I were walking along we found a
beheaded chicken and I had no idea what
this was and I I joked I said oh I guess
he ran out of the restaurant you know he
made it out of the kitchen before they
could cook him but my buddy said said no
you know this is probably some Voodoo
thing probably some witchcraft ritual
and I didn't really believe him when he
said it but there's a lot of occult
stuff out in California there is
probably California you you see a
spiritually what it moves in there and
when you see there's a lot of sexual
immorality sexual immorality comes
together with the occultism sexual
immorality moves with witchcraft he also
moves with poverty and death addictions
so when you see in an area that moving
those type of things there some sort of
witchcraft